hey youtubers happy 2017 so starting the
year off right Ben Affleck just trolling
the fandom just a little bit about the
Batman movie so I'm gonna explain what's
going on he talked about maybe they're
not gonna do it so I included the most
epic of Ben Affleck rants and this it'll
make you so excited about the Batman
movie there is a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and just leave
a Batman related comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything so
what's going on is Ben Affleck really
trolling fans maybe I won't do the
Batman movie you know there's not a
script if it's not great we're not gonna
do anything so there's just so much
stuff going on that makes me believe
that this is not completely true Rob
Liefeld actually had like a hot take
where he's like that's called leverage
because Ben Affleck is writing the
script with Geoff Johns of course and
he's directing meaning that as the actor
who is doing all these other things too
he effectively has almost complete
creative control over the Batman movie
which as a creator is what you want but
the thing is is that Batman is the
biggest franchise that Warner Brothers
has had in the last twenty to thirty
years like it's literally the biggest
money earner they've ever had next to
Harry Potter in the junior tolki movies
like The Hobbit and The Lord of the
Rings so they're not gonna take that and
let anybody do whatever they want to
with it no matter how awesome they are
and how big they've been blowing it up
in Hollywood because when you think of
Ben Affleck like a bunch of different
pictures come into your mind like you
think of Kevin Smith era Ben Affleck you
think of daredevil Jennifer Garner era
Ben Affleck and then you think of like
director era Ben Affleck that brought
him to today like the person who wins
Oscars for directing movies but what's
the actual quote that everybody's been
circulating and freaking out about so
there was a big profile on him for his
other movies like he's doing live by
night that's being released in a couple
weeks we'll talk about that in a second
because it's the next big candidate next
to the Superbowl for the new Justice
League trailer so that's like a
completely separate thing but they're
doing this big profile on Ben Affleck
you know how much his life has changed
now that he's been directing all these
award-winning movies and he's taken on
the persona of the Batman
so when they asked him about the Batman
movie that he is making he says well
that's the idea but it's not a set thing
and there's no script which makes you
freak out a little bit but then goes on
to say if it doesn't come together in a
way I think is really great I'm not
going to do it so I think we're all in
agreement when we say Ben Affleck is
definitely gonna do the Batman movie
it's just that they're trying to avoid
repeating the past so they want to wait
for the right script with the right
creative before they actually start
rolling cameras and start scheduling
stuff like scheduling a release date
even though they've kind of pushed the
second Justice League a little bit
further out than it was supposed to drop
to make room for the Batman movie
they're just like hoping that it all
comes together and it drops during 2018
so when Ben Affleck says that they don't
have a script yet really what I think
he's saying is that they don't have a
finished script they've been working on
the Batman movie like Geoff Johns was
almost radio silent for all of last year
but he has a whole bunch of other stuff
on his plate in addition to the Batman
movie so like at the beginning of this
year like Geoff Johns just went on this
complete rant where he's like I'm so
excited about all the stuff that's
coming like it was it was wonderful cuz
he's been so quiet for so long but he
was talking about the Wonder Woman movie
just because that's the next big DC
movie he was involved in that but it's
sort of like tail-end zack snyder's so I
think the Zack Snyder's wife was still a
producer on the film so it's sort of
like the beginning of geoff johns era
but it's not like 100% geoff johns
creative and then they've been editing
the Justice League film in getting
Aquaman off the ground so now that Geoff
Johns is like one of the new gods of DC
films inside Warner Brothers he just has
like so many other projects to take care
of so he had to stop writing comics for
a little while which was a huge bummer
which is done now because he said I will
be writing comics again it like tweeted
this Watchmen picture so it's like okay
Geoff Johns clearly gonna do some big
Watchmen comic that's part of the new DC
rebirth arc so really excited about that
but then he talked about the new DC TV
show that I did a video about yesterday
and even though he was kind of quiet
about it there's also the Batman movie
but just because that's so far off
there's still a lot about the movie
the characters they put in it the story
they go with that could change that they
just don't want to talk too much about
it and then have it all be different
when it actually gets here so while it
is really funny to hear Ben Affleck sort
of like mess with people a little bit
and this is actually with the Guardian
that he's talking to so while it is kind
of funny to hear Ben Affleck say that he
might not do the Batman movie really I
think that's just like a little bit of
him hedging his bets and his sense of
humor because like if you talked to
Kevin Smith he tells the best Ben
Affleck stories like I said there's like
three different eras of Ben Affleck
depending on who you're talking to
there's like the Kevin Smith young Ben
Affleck who he says was just like crazy
fun to hang out with that's from like
the 90s all the way up to the early
2000s then he starts to hit it big Kevin
Smith tells this funny story about how
he would just go off just open his mouth
and get in so much trouble going on
rants it would sometimes get him in
trouble and cost him movie projects
really good example of that is him going
off on deflategate which isn't a
Hollywood issue but you have to imagine
him being like this as a young person in
Hollywood all the time about Hollywood
stuff so this is just hilarious watch
this this likud is the ultimate [ __ ]
[ __ ] outrage of sports ever it's so
[ __ ] stupid
that I can't believe you really they
gave him a suspension for a quarter of
the regular season which would be
equivalent of suspending a baseball
player for 40 [ __ ] days for yet
quarter days yeah exactly
which is what they do for when you get
busted taking steroids right which and
by the way if the NFL had a real testing
it really knew how to test for steroids
and HGH in theater there'd be no [ __ ]
NF Grey
so instead what they what they did was
to spend time ready for four days for
not giving him his [ __ ] cell phone
that's and for having a friend who
called himself the deflator if I got in
trouble for all the things that my
friends called themselves yeah it would
be finished okay you want to give a guy
because he doesn't give you a cell phone
as a punishment I would never give up
that organization as leak prone as the
NFL my [ __ ] cell phone so you could
just look through my emails and listen
to my voice especially in the NFL that
the league that
makes everything that's right so first
thing we're gonna do is leak this [ __ ]
and I don't know maybe it's it's funny
lovely sex messages from his wife maybe
it's just friendly message from his wife
maybe it's maybe Tom Brady so [ __ ]
classy and such a [ __ ] gentleman that
he doesn't want people to know that he
may have reflected on his real opinion
of some of his coworkers
right like guys he plays with guys he
plays against his real feelings
I wouldn't want guys who I didn't think
we're very good to know I didn't think
they were very good I wouldn't want guys
who I who I thought were great to know I
thought they were great I want my keep
my opinions to myself
surely his opinions about professional
football contained in his emails and his
texts and his [ __ ] telephone
I'm not giving your telephone there not
the FBI you're not required this isn't
[ __ ] federal subpoena we're not
required to turn over your bank records
it's really about a conspiracy if people
working inside the NFL who all come from
organizations that Tom Brady whipped
their ass over the last 10 and 15 years
so those guys would work for the [ __ ]
Jets and the Broncos and everybody else
who are now going like get him hang him
you know because because they have some
slight flimsy [ __ ] pretense and Tom
is so class so you agree it's a smear
campaign it's a [ __ ] ridiculous so I
would have included more of that it was
just so epic but because it's about
football not about you know DC comic
book Batman related stuff you just you
get the idea don't you wish that actors
felt free enough to speak their mind in
that way without fear of reprisal from
big studios pulling projects out from
under them it's just like the best thing
ever this is your glorious F bomb
dropping Batman that you've been waiting
for this whole time so we got a
publicist and Kevin Smith kind of jokes
that the publicist told him to start
shutting his mouth so you have like the
jeely era Ben Affleck after that his
career sort of craters and then he has
the Renaissance when he sort of
reinvents himself as a director in like
the other big thing that happened right
before that is that he met Jennifer
Garner so you sort of have like the
director era Ben Affleck in the Jennifer
Garner era Ben Affleck around the same
time that was around 2005 2007 because
Gone Baby Gone was like his first big
movie to direct so that's sort of like
the beginning of the Ben Affleck that
you're seeing
today like the more creative visionary
author version of Ben Affleck so I'm
really interested to see what his Batman
movie is like most people just look at
Ben Affleck and they see daredevil or
they see like the Kevin Smith era Ben
Affleck but he's really completely
different like Kevin Smith talks a lot
about him like he's really sad because
they don't hang out anymore he's like
yeah I haven't really hung out with Ben
Affleck in the last 10 years or so since
he started going out with Jennifer
Garner he attributes that to Jennifer
Garner just absolutely hating him
because of the way that he used to talk
with Ben Affleck like they used to make
fun of each other like friends do but
she took it a little personally so they
had a big falling out and that was the
end of Kevin Smith hanging out with Ben
Affleck
it's really fun to see Kevin Smith doing
all the DC TV stuff now so this is sort
of like his second wind in superhero
land but it's kind of funny to see him
wistfully remember his time hanging out
with the person who is now the biggest
star on the planet playing Batman so
given the way Kevin Smith talks about
Ben Affleck behind the scenes like the
real Ben Affleck the one that you don't
see in front of all the cameras is he's
just messing with people a little bit
everything is gonna be fine with the
Batman movie he just trolling just a
little bit having a little bit of fun so
at the end of the day they're just
trying to avoid running into like a
Batman Returns to Batman Forever and
Batman and Robin trajectory like they
don't want this to all go down the
toilet then I have to wait like another
10 years for another Christopher Nolan
to come along and just for those that
are asking Christopher Nolan hasn't been
involved creatively with any of the DC
stuff that they've done since the Man of
Steel movie came out that was his last
time consulting on a DC project and he
wasn't even that involved with that
movie like he had a producer credit on
it and I think that they brought him in
just because his time on Batman had been
so influential on the way people thought
of superheroes like it was such a real
take on the Batman and they wanted to do
that same thing for Superman even though
I think that was kind of a mistake like
Man of Steel was a fun movie but it
wasn't quite as fun as it could have
been but you have to remember that a lot
of the producers like the people in
creative control over the movies have
largely been shuffled out of Warner
Brothers and people like Jeff Jones have
been brought in
so one of the biggest things they did
during 2016 which is you know making me
really excited for 2017 is change the
creative energy behind the scenes like
the people pulling the strings are now
the right people pulling the strings so
worst case scenario when they say you
know if the script doesn't come together
we're not gonna do a Batman movie it's
just gonna take a little bit longer to
get here which I'm totally fine with
like it's okay if they push the Batman
movie even like another year just
because they can't crack the script
there are so many superhero comic books
Star Wars movies coming in the next two
years that if one of them doesn't come
you won't notice like there's literally
more movies than most kids have money to
pay to go see so do not freak out but
let me know like what do you guys think
about Ben Affleck just messing with
people behind the scenes just like hey
you know maybe I won't do a Batman movie
like we all totally think that he's
gonna do the Batman movie there's no way
that he's not gonna do it eventually it
just might not happen right away but for
those of you asking about the Justice
League trailer so I actually didn't
realize that they bumped his live by
night movie so because that's coming out
within two weeks of the Superbowl I
would not be surprised if that's when
the Justice League trailer comes because
originally his movie was going to be a
Christmas movie so I'm like okay that's
probably when they're gonna drop some
new Justice League footage and then
they'll do something else when the Super
Bowl happens but because they pushed it
it's all coming out around the same time
so that just seems like the next best
place for it to drop but when they do
drop it it's gonna look a lot more
polished than the stuff that they
dropped so far like even the Comic Con
footage that they dropped earlier was
just work print the behind the scenes
video were just green-screen it was
literally just somebody filming them
walking around on the sets it wasn't
like actual finished footage so it is
gonna be an awesome 2017 and this is
just talking about the DC stuff this has
nothing to do with all the big Marvel
stuff and Star Wars Episode 8 you have
to remember there's all that other stuff
that's dropping this year so what I'm
gonna do later today is post a video for
like all the big stuff that's coming
just in the next couple of months
like for instance Legion is a brand new
x-men TV show that's dropping on FX so
most people might not be aware of some
of the stuff that's coming
there's a couple really cool things that
drop during Christmas like trollhunters
that you may not have seen so I'm just
gonna do a video for that next later
tonight so look out for that but I will
say congratulations to the latest flash
ring giveaway winner Sean J pleads
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video I'll just announce
the winner the next time I post the DC
video what you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn all
about that new DC TV show that's coming
this year and you can click here to
rewatch that justice league footage
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight